cuando estamos trabajando con una celda
voltaica es importante relacionar el
potencial de la celda con la energía
libre de esta reacción redox cierto y
aquí tenemos la ecuación que relaciona
la energía libre verdad con el potencial
de la celda así que delta g delta que
sería el cambio en la energía libre y
sabemos que para una reacción espontánea
delta g tiene que ser negativa así que
déjenme escribir esto acá delta g delta
g tiene que ser negativa y tiene que ser
negativa para las reacciones espontáneas
de tipo redox verdad que tenemos por
ejemplo en nuestra celda voltaica y
ahora vamos a calcular el valor del
delta g verdad para el final de este
vídeo pero vamos a utilizar esta fórmula
que tenemos aquí ahora bien es la letra
digamos que en este caso representa el
potencial de la celda o el voltaje de la
celda verdad y es bastante fácil de
medir simplemente nos fijamos en un
simplemente nos fijamos en
multímetro y podríamos ver que por
ejemplo para esta celda el potencial de
celda es de más 1 punto 10 volts muy
bien
1.10 volts así que es realmente fácil
medir el voltaje asociado a una celda
voltaica ahora bien la letra n la letra
n representa los moles de electrones que
son transferidos en esta reacción red 2
y en este en este ejemplo estamos
hablando de dos moles de electrones y
finalmente la letra f representa la
constante de faraday y la constante de
faraday es la cantidad de carga llevada
por un molde electrones así que de hecho
podríamos calcular la constante de
parada y así que vamos a hacerlo digamos
a hacerlo por acá arriba ok
calculemos la constante de faraday y
ahora bien nosotros sabemos que un
electrón tiene una carga de 1.6 por 10 a
la menos 19 colom es verdad porque cool
oms es la unidad para las cargas para la
carga así que vamos a escribir eso de
hecho podríamos ser un poco más preciso
en realidad es 1.6 0 2 0 2 por 10 a la
menos 19 cool oms por electrón verdad es
la carga de cada uno de los electrones
ahora bien si queremos encontrar la
magnitud de la carga que es llevada por
un molde electrones entonces tenemos que
multiplicar por el número de avogadro y
si multiplicamos por el número de
avogadro que sabemos que es 6 puntos 0
22 por 10 a las 23 estos serían el
número de electrones que hay digamos en
un mol
mol de electrones un molde electrones
si multiplicamos estas dos cantidades
por un lado se cancelan los electrones y
nos quedan cool oms por mol verdad por
mol de electrones y podríamos sacar la
calculadora para hacer estas operaciones
muy bien vamos a ponerlo aquí entonces
tendremos 1.602 por 10 a la menos 19 ok
ahí lo tenemos eso sería este primer
factor y luego eso hay que multiplicarlo
por 6.0 22 por 10 a la 23 y eso nos da
el siguiente resultado 96 mil 472 96 mil
472 punto 44 pero vamos a vamos a
redondear lo y dejarlo simplemente como
96 mil 472
por mol por mol de electrones por
supuesto y si hacemos un cálculo un
poquito más cuidadoso veremos que el
resultado en realidad sería 96 mil 485
kilos por mol muy bien pero bueno en
algunas en algunas ocasiones es lo que
verás en ciertos libros de texto tan
también a veces se encuentra el
siguiente número que es digamos un
redondeo que serían 96 mil 500 cool oms
fórmulas y que depende del libro de
texto que estés utilizando podrás ver
quizás algunas de estas cantidades
simplemente nosotros vamos a manejar
96.500 cullum por mol así que esto es
bastante bueno para los cálculos que
vamos a hacer y bueno aquí ya tenemos
explicado cada uno de los términos de
esta ecuación que teníamos desde el
inicio así que el potencial de las
celdas de la que ya hemos hablado es
1.10
ahí está
y de hecho este es el potencial de celda
estándar que es el voltaje medido cuando
la celda opera bajo condiciones estándar
verdad y esto está definido para cuando
nuestros sólidos están en forma pura y
este es el caso verdad porque estamos
trabajando con un metal de zinc así que
es está en su forma sólida pura y cuando
y aquí tenemos también el metal de cobre
verdad que está en su forma sólida y
pura así que también está en las
condiciones estándar están definidas
tomando las soluciones a concentración 1
molar así que aquí deberíamos tener una
concentración 1 molar de sulfato de zinc
que eso eso sería una concentración de 1
molar y eso nos brinda también una
solución 1 molar verdad de de jong de
zinc 2 positivo ahora también tendremos
una concentración 1 molar de sulfato de
cobre que nos dará en solución un unión
de cobre 2 positivo
de lo anterior para garantizar las
condiciones estándar necesitamos que
todo esto se lleve a una temperatura de
25 grados celsius muy bien así que todo
esto estará a 25 grados celsius así que
si tenemos estas condiciones si nos
fijamos en el voltímetro entonces este
es el voltaje que vamos a obtener verdad
y de hecho podemos modificar un poquito
la ecuación de la que hemos estado
hablando simplemente agregando un super
índice de este lado así que vamos a
escribir es cero es cero en lugar de
porque el cero sería nuestro potencial
de es el de estándar eso significa que
todo está bajo condiciones estándar muy
bien y por lo tanto esto sería delta g
cero muy bien sería delta g cero que es
el cambio estándar en la energía libre
así que vamos a resolver cuál es el
valor para delta g cero y nosotros ya
sabemos que tiene que ser negativo
porque es una reacción espontánea así
que vamos a invocar todos todos los
números que tenemos aquí solo que vamos
a hacernos
más despacio aquí tenemos más espacio
así que nuestro cambio en la energía
libre bajo condiciones estándar sería
negativo por un lado porque bueno vamos
a detallar un poquito más en ello
después pero bueno tendremos después n
donde n era el número de moles verdad y
nosotros sabemos que el número de moles
eran dos eran dos moles de electrones
así que tendremos dos moles muy bien
estos son dos moles de electrones y
ahora ponemos la constante de parada y
verdad vamos déjenme retomarlo aquí la
constante de faraday que nosotros
dijimos que eran 96 mil 596 mil 500
colones por mol así que ponemos 96 mil
500 colones
mol de electrones y finalmente ponemos
el valor del potencial de shell de
estándar verdad que era cero y que
nosotros dijimos que era 1.10 volts y
entonces tú te estarás preguntando bueno
aquí estamos poniendo volts pero cuáles
serán agua que equivalen los volts
recordemos que un volts sería jules
sobre colom verdad entonces aquí lo que
tenemos es mas 1.10 yus sobre colom así
que si nosotros hacemos las operaciones
primero veamos cuáles son las unidades
que nos restan primero los colomos se
cancelan y también se cancelan los moles
así que el resultado esencialmente nos
dará en jules así que hagamos estas
cuentas vamos a hacerlo en la
calculadora tenemos 2 que multiplica a
96.500 que multiplica a 1.10
y eso nos da como resultado 212 1300
jules verdad si lo redondeamos eso
serían sólo 200 12.000 jules y en
términos de kilo jules simplemente
serían 212 kilos jules muy bien así que
digamos hagámonos un poquito más
despacio el cambio en la energía libre
en bajo condiciones estándar sería menos
menos 212 kilo
jules quizás debería hacerlo hacer más
bonitas estas letras serían kilo jules y
lo que hemos estado mencionando es que
cuando el delta g es negativo entonces
tenemos una reacción espontánea verdad
es una reacción espontánea de tipo redox
la que tenemos aquí y no tenemos que
delta g cero
es cero tienen signos opuestos verdad
teníamos un signo positivo cuando
hablábamos del voltaje del potencial
estándar para la celda y nosotros
concluimos con un signo negativo para la
del traje de verdad aquí tenemos nuestro
signo negativo que son menos 212 kilos
jules y esa es la razón por la cual
tenemos ese signo negativo en nuestra
ecuación verdad para que cuando tengamos
un potencial de celda positivo entonces
obtengamos una reacción espontánea en la
celda voltaica cierto así que un valor
positivo para el voltaje tendremos nos
dará como consecuencia un valor negativo
en el cambio de la energía libre y eso
nos indica una reacción espontánea